تعاني عائله ام العبد ظروفا قاسيه في مخيم
الفهد للنازحين قرب ادلب فقدوا بصرهم
جميعا جراء عامل وراثي
تشتاق مروه الى اللاعب مع اقرانها
وتتمنى عصريه ان ترجع الى مدرستها ان عاد
بصرها
بالبصيره وحسب تعينهم والدتهم في الطعام
والشراب
والله بالليل انا ما اشوف الحزب نهار اشوى
شويه والبنات عندي ما يشوفون خالص يعني ما
يطلع خالص لا بالنهار ولا بالليل بالليل
خالص
والله وضعنا مشتويه ما نشوف خالصين كل
نهار يعني يعني وضع الشتاء سيء جدا وامنا
وان شاء الله امنا انه يسره العمليات
ويعني
بلكي نشوف اني احسن وضعن احسن من هيك
بلكي ان شاء الله الله يساعدنا واهل الخير
ان شاء الله يساعدونا
من الحروق في يديها اوقدت ام العبد نار
موقدها
وبكدماتها تعرفت على دروب المخيم
معاناه المكفوفين في مخيمات النازحين دفعت
بعض المنظمات الانسانيه الى التركيز على
هذه الفئه وتجهيز تجمعات لهم توجد فيها
خدمات يصعب توفيرها في المخيمات العشوائيه
تشكل البيوت المجهزه حلما للمكفوفين في
المخيمات انتقل ابو عادل منذ عام الى قريه
النور للمكفوفين
[تصفيق]
يذهب الى المسجد ولقضاء حاجات منزله دون
انتظار المساعده من احد نحن قاعدين في
مخيمات عشوائيه الكفيف كثير ما كان مرتاح
فيها بسبب السكك والحبال والتنقل بين
الخيم انه على المنافع انه مثلا ياخذ
عيالها ياخذون ويرجعهن لا هون اجينا على
هالقريه الكفيف لقد كثير الامور فيها مثل
الطرق الجدران اللي عليها ارقام مثل هذا
الجدران حروف النافره كتير كتير ارتحنا
فيها هون ككفيفين القائمون على القريه
يستخدمون لغه بريل في كل تفاصيل البناء
وفي ارضيات المنازل ليستدل المكفوف على
اجزاء المنزل
رغم رياده فكره انشاء قريه خاصه
بالمكفوفين في هذه الديار فانها عالجت
اوضاع عدد قليل منهم ويكفي ان يتوفر الدعم
من الذين عليهم القيام بذلك او ممن يمكنهم
الدعم لتخفيف معانات كثير من المكفوفين في
شمال غربي سوريا
ادهم ابو الحسام الجزيره